Caption: all right uh so yeah today i'm talking
Caption: about feature toggles so let's toggle
Caption: some features
Caption: um before we start this is a picture of
Caption: my face with a circle in it
Caption: and my name
Caption: if you wanted to tweet anything at me
Caption: that's um that's my twitter handle and
Caption: there's a website there with some more
Caption: stuff about me if you wanted to have a
Caption: look um this talk will be put up there
Caption: um once they're made available on
Caption: youtube
Caption: another thing before we start uh thank
Caption: you to our amazing sponsors um
Caption: we keep saying that
Caption: uh sorry that uh ddd doesn't happen um
Caption: without the sponsors but i think it's
Caption: just as much everyone who's bought a
Caption: ticket and is sitting here as well um
Caption: doesn't happen without the audience and
Caption: buying for tickets so thank you
Caption: all right so i want to start by going
Caption: back to the title image i put on my uh
Caption: on my slide here does anyone know where
Caption: this image is from
Caption: yeah it uh it's from uh a movie called
Caption: the martian which was released in 2018.
Caption: uh it's an image of the nasa mission
Caption: control center in the context of that
Caption: movie
Caption: um so it's set slightly in the future
Caption: it's more futuristic than what you might
Caption: be used to
Caption: um and i think it's definitely a bit of
Caption: a cliche to use an image like this in my
Caption: title slide like you might be getting a
Caption: feeling of deja vu like you've seen this
Caption: talk before
Caption: and i understand right like nasa's cool
Caption: and space is really cool and sometimes
Caption: launching a new piece of software to the
Caption: world feels a bit like this
Caption: but i'm using this image for my title
Caption: slide with some irony because i think
Caption: this actually represents the opposite of
Caption: what we want to do in the real world is
Caption: why
Caption: nasa typically has to work really hard
Caption: to prevent anything going wrong for
Caption: obvious reasons
Caption: that's why they have mission control
Caption: launching people into space is very
Caption: expensive and very dangerous
Caption: more so when something goes wrong we
Caption: want to avoid that
Caption: so i'm not going to spoil it but for
Caption: those who might not have seen this movie
Caption: the mission does go very wrong basically
Caption: there's an incident and one of the
Caption: astronauts his name is mark watney
Caption: is left on mars by himself
Caption: probably goes without saying that
Caption: this kind of incident was unexpected so
Caption: no amount of planning or pre-preparation
Caption: could have prepared them for this
Caption: scenario
Caption: and i think the real problem with this
Caption: image or the real problem with
Caption: the people in mission control was not a
Caption: single person in this room
Caption: has any agency to to help him fix this
Caption: problem mark's out there on his own
Caption: they can't provide any direct support to
Caption: mark
Caption: they actually couldn't communicate with
Caption: him either
Caption: mostly all they can really do is just
Caption: sit in front of those screens and watch
Caption: as everything happens
Caption: i think we can draw some comparisons to
Caption: this situation in history
Caption: uh in the history of software
Caption: development our software development
Caption: so microsoft windows is historically
Caption: very very expensive piece of software to
Caption: build
Caption: um much like a rocket launch right
Caption: microsoft has to spend an enormous
Caption: amount of money to make sure that there
Caption: are a few as few bugs as possible
Caption: um they have to be absolutely certain
Caption: that everything works before they burn
Caption: their copy of that software onto that
Caption: disk because once it's on that disk
Caption: and then once they put that disk inside
Caption: the box and then they put that box
Caption: inside a bigger box in a truck
Caption: there's basically nothing they can do
Caption: after that point
Caption: uh fixing something after launch for for
Caption: microsoft for windows engineers is an
Caption: exercise that's very very expensive
Caption: there are a lot of changes and new
Caption: releases in this particular
Caption: version of windows so this delayed the
Caption: launch and then thusly increased the
Caption: risk
Caption: and this meant that more testing was
Caption: going to be required
Caption: so microsoft always tests
Caption: windows with a lot of different
Caption: configurations of hardware and stuff
Caption: like that but vista failed because of
Caption: unforeseen
Caption: circumstances that happened after launch
Caption: so essentially they were testing the
Caption: wrong things
Caption: essentially what happened with vista
Caption: particularly was they were at odds at
Caption: the time with
Caption: their hardware
Caption: developers
Caption: and then those hardware builders
Caption: as maybe a better word they went against
Caption: the advice of microsoft and shipped
Caption: configurations that weren't really
Caption: compatible with this software
Caption: so this was an unexpected event
Caption: it's probably a little bit unfair to
Caption: pick on vista because a lot of the same
Caption: problems were true of any piece of
Caption: software at the time and any windows
Caption: release or any like any large releases
Caption: of software at the time it was pretty
Caption: common
Caption: so going back to the martian for a
Caption: little bit
Caption: this is an image from a scene without
Caption: spoiling anything again hopefully
Caption: uh it's an image from a scene where mark
Caption: was able to make first contact with
Caption: mission control back on earth
Caption: um so he used a pretty clever hack
Caption: to to get this to work it was it was
Caption: quite an interesting part of the movie
Caption: um but
Caption: nonetheless communication was still
Caption: pretty slow and difficult and that's a
Caption: problem so if if mark was a windows
Caption: vista user we'd probably describe him as
Caption: a power user
Caption: and the fact that he was able to
Caption: communicate with the crew on earth at
Caption: all was actually largely incidental
Caption: this is probably
Caption: the same could really be said for
Caption: windows vista as well
Caption: customers would
Caption: typically buy a new machine that a
Caption: typical customer not a power user would
Caption: buy a machine
Caption: um and they'd quickly find all of these
Caption: bugs that were common amongst uh lots of
Caption: people who bought this
Caption: um and it was very difficult for them to
Caption: communicate with the engineers that
Caption: built microsoft microsoft windows as
Caption: well as um
Caption: they couldn't really get the support
Caption: they needed
Caption: there's if they did get in touch with
Caption: support there was often very little that
Caption: those microsoft engineers could do
Caption: because they had software that was burnt
Caption: onto a disk so it was very difficult to
Caption: change at that point
Caption: and
Caption: ask the question
Caption: is this something that we really want
Caption: for our customers whether it be our
Caption: customer
Caption: alone by himself on mars or a customer
Caption: who's bought a machine with windows
Caption: vista on it i don't think so i think
Caption: we've learned enough about software
Caption: development over the years vista was a
Caption: long time ago that we can do better
Caption: and that's exactly what feature toggles
Caption: are for
Caption: so quick outline
Caption: i'm going to go through a really quick a
Caption: bridge history of feature toggles
Caption: that's important
Caption: and then i'm going to talk about what
Caption: exactly a feature toggle is and then i'm
Caption: going to finish on some techniques and
Caption: strategy
Caption: so the story of feature toggle starts
Caption: with this book um it was written by some
Caption: microsoft engineers who built microsoft
Caption: word early versions of word and excel
Caption: and one version of windows i can't
Caption: remember which one it was released in
Caption: about 1995
Caption: might be windows 95 in that case um so
Caption: it's kind of an old book and i haven't
Caption: actually read it i'm not i'm not going
Caption: to admit that i've read this and i
Caption: probably won't recommend reading it
Caption: either i don't think a lot of the
Caption: information in here is relevant anymore
Caption: but it does have one interesting
Caption: section in the book uh it goes through
Caption: the details of how microsoft was
Caption: developing software at that time what
Caption: their process was
Caption: um essentially it was a 10-step process
Caption: and it would probably look pretty
Caption: familiar to most people now
Caption: even though this was set in 1995
Caption: this process has a name
Caption: it's not it's not exactly like this now
Caption: in modern software development but this
Caption: process is something that we use today
Caption: and it's called trunk based development
Caption: so trunk based development actually as
Caption: it turns out was pretty much
Caption: it was getting pushed by um a lot of
Caption: people around that time um
Caption: starting in around 1985 to 2005. so you
Caption: had this book that came out it was 1995
Caption: but around the same time thought works
Caption: were really pushing this as well they
Caption: had a piece of um it was a build server
Caption: called cruise control
Caption: and that was really kind of pushing the
Caption: idea of continuous integration
Caption: and then something happened
Caption: we had git and github not to say that
Caption: either of these software are
Caption: particularly bad like um who uses git i
Caption: think everyone does right yeah
Caption: it introduced the idea of distributed
Caption: version control first of all
Caption: but also lightweight branching so
Caption: branching before
Caption: git came along was this exercise that
Caption: was quite heavy um
Caption: it wasn't slow or anything like that or
Caption: difficult but uh you did need to take an
Caption: entire copy of all the code and create a
Caption: branch with that um whereas was able to
Caption: do that without taking an entire copy of
Caption: all your code all at once so it took up
Caption: disk space
Caption: and then github came along shortly after
Caption: and introduced the idea of pull requests
Caption: so if you think about those steps in
Caption: that process there was a step where if
Caption: we've
Caption: successfully built our software and all
Caption: the tests passed and we've run our smoke
Caption: tests and stuff like that we can just
Caption: merge that software straight back into
Caption: whatever we're working on microsoft word
Caption: for example so our feature goes straight
Caption: in but pull requests add another layer
Caption: of friction there in order to get your
Caption: software into the product um by creating
Caption: a step where you have to have a review
Caption: first sometimes
Caption: i don't know if anyone's experienced
Caption: this but have a pull request open for
Caption: several days takes a long time that's
Caption: just adding friction to the process
Caption: so people got fed up with this
Caption: and then some developments start to come
Caption: out after that so around the end of 2010
Caption: a couple of books came out so we have
Caption: the book by
Caption: dave farley and jess humble that's
Caption: continuous delivery
Caption: really pushing the idea of
Caption: high degrees of automation lots of
Caption: avoiding manual testing
Caption: and trunk-based development is part of
Caption: that book as well as well as accelerate
Caption: you might have seen some other people in
Caption: this conference talking about that book
Caption: as well
Caption: and these also coincide with the devops
Caption: movement and various other things as
Caption: well and this is where our story of
Caption: feature toggle starts
Caption: so i want to talk about something
Caption: that is in the continuous delivery book
Caption: by dave farley it's this idea of cones
Caption: of change
Caption: so you can imagine two developers are
Caption: working on a new feature so they're
Caption: working inside the same repository for
Caption: example
Caption: and we can imagine working on that
Caption: feature as the culmination of a numerous
Caption: changes so we'll open up a file we'll
Caption: make a little change there we'll open up
Caption: another file maybe add new files delete
Caption: files and stuff like that
Caption: and that accumulation of change is is
Caption: known as a cone of change and the
Caption: problem with
Caption: uh large amounts of change is or the
Caption: culmination of lots of change is that
Caption: eventually that cone gets wide enough
Caption: that it might clash with other cones
Caption: we can see those collisions there
Caption: those collisions are in the form of
Caption: merge conflicts but also it can be code
Caption: that
Caption: is going completely in two different
Caption: directions it's really not able to be
Caption: merged it gets difficult
Caption: so we can see that yeah the wider our
Caption: kind of change the more likely we are to
Caption: have
Caption: collisions there that are hard to hard
Caption: to work with so how do we fix that
Caption: picks up with the idea of continuous
Caption: integration so instead of thinking about
Caption: features what we can do instead is start
Caption: to think about something that's smaller
Caption: than a feature just a small change some
Caption: some part of a feature but not the whole
Caption: thing because those features could be
Caption: too big and could be creating too many
Caption: of those large cones
Caption: so
Caption: if we're going to go and change this up
Caption: so that we're using continuous
Caption: integration instead it will look
Caption: something like this
Caption: instead of
Caption: keeping that feature to ourselves and
Caption: building and building a building upon it
Caption: let's commit
Caption: to the trunk this is trunk based
Caption: development um small changes
Caption: and and
Caption: yeah then what we can see here is we're
Caption: not seeing those kinds of changes we're
Caption: not seeing any sort of collisions there
Caption: so that's continuous integration
Caption: if we look at trunk based development
Caption: versus something more traditional like
Caption: feature branches now we go from having
Caption: our branches be something that's
Caption: long-lived um feature branches you might
Caption: find you have a long-lived branch that's
Caption: uh per environment for example so that's
Caption: almost like the longest loop branch you
Caption: can have you're not going to have an
Caption: environment like dev
Caption: come and go that's around forever
Caption: versus something like a trunk based
Caption: approach where branches are all geared
Caption: to be short-lived as short as possible
Caption: what typically happens with feature
Caption: branches is the batch size for a release
Caption: as in a new version that's usable for
Caption: your customers
Caption: is a number of features
Caption: just because you'll have to align a
Caption: whole bunch of things and it tends to
Caption: align that you can release a bunch of
Caption: features all at once
Caption: whereas releasing trunk based software
Caption: we might be releasing
Caption: something less than a feature that batch
Caption: size is going to be smaller than that
Caption: as well as that because
Caption: we're not releasing huge amounts of
Caption: change all at once our change risk goes
Caption: from being high to low instead
Caption: so to summarize trunk based development
Caption: it's a branching model for code cable a
Caption: collaboration on a single branch
Caption: and that's an enabler of continuous
Caption: integration
Caption: hopefully that that makes sense
Caption: cool so what exactly is a feature toggle
Caption: what is where do feature toggles come
Caption: into this
Caption: uh let's take a definition
Caption: so a feature toggle is a software
Caption: engineering technique for enabling
Caption: feature life cycle management with or
Caption: without deploying new code
Caption: so who's used feature toggles before
Caption: that's quite a few people too
Caption: um just the with or without part without
Caption: with or without deploying your code
Caption: does that does that sound a bit odd
Caption: it did to me i had maybe a picture of
Caption: how feature toggles work um and the idea
Caption: to me was
Caption: we can deploy a piece of software and we
Caption: can fiddle with it we can change things
Caption: turn them off and on without having to
Caption: deploy new code
Caption: but actually it turns out it's something
Caption: larger than that
Caption: so let's go into it
Caption: here's some code that is a feature
Caption: toggle
Caption: feature toggle code um let's go through
Caption: it
Caption: we have this function here this is
Caption: typescript by the way we have this
Caption: feature here we can ask for a feature by
Caption: name and this function will tell us
Caption: whether that feature is enabled not
Caption: we'll wrap it in a functional interface
Caption: called feature toggle
Caption: and then we can use that functional
Caption: interface
Caption: to
Caption: whether a feature is disabled or not run
Caption: uh one branch of code or another
Caption: so who can tell me
Caption: uh we don't have to answer this
Caption: very quite difficult but who can tell me
Caption: what happens when this code runs or who
Caption: knows
Caption: problem is we don't know
Caption: what we actually don't have here is an
Caption: implementation all we have is interfaces
Caption: and stuff like that so i don't know
Caption: which log message i'm going to get i
Caption: don't have that information
Caption: so what that interface alone isn't
Caption: telling me is what's the persistence of
Caption: this feature toggle like where does the
Caption: value live it could live in some
Caption: database or it could live in sorry a
Caption: relational database nosql database it
Caption: could leave in some sort of flat file
Caption: um we live in a json file or some format
Caption: that i've never seen before
Caption: there's third-party services where we
Caption: can get our feature talkers from so
Caption: launch darkly is
Caption: the most common one i think
Caption: as well as it could just be something we
Caption: calculate on the fly or it could just be
Caption: something that lives in the code
Caption: somewhere
Caption: it also doesn't tell me when this
Caption: feature toggle is evaluated
Caption: so this could be evaluated per request
Caption: every time we request it it could
Caption: potentially be different or maybe we
Caption: resolve all the values of our feature
Caption: toggles at startup
Caption: um so that they once we start up the
Caption: application they're always the same
Caption: maybe it's something that we resolve at
Caption: build time so we can build different
Caption: versions with different feature toggles
Caption: but they once they're built they stay
Caption: the same
Caption: or perhaps it's something that's just
Caption: completely static it's just always the
Caption: same
Caption: regardless of when you build it or when
Caption: you run it
Caption: it also doesn't describe the longevity
Caption: of the feature toggle like how long is
Caption: this designed to last for how long how
Caption: long is this meant to be a feature
Caption: toggle for it could be somewhere between
Caption: hours or years and i think years really
Caption: means it definitely
Caption: a very long time
Caption: it also doesn't really describe some
Caption: aspects of the behavior
Caption: so
Caption: we don't know anything about the input
Caption: validation here what if that feature is
Caption: one that i'm not familiar with me is the
Caption: code
Caption: what should happen there should there be
Caption: some sort of safe fallback
Caption: should the default value be false or
Caption: true should it throw an exception
Caption: because i don't really know what the
Caption: default value is
Caption: and it doesn't really give me any idea
Caption: whether the
Caption: output of this is consistent at all
Caption: so not much there that an interface can
Caption: tell us
Caption: i've got a hypothesis
Caption: let's implement our feature toggle this
Caption: way so this is this is a feature toggle
Caption: service called always off and what we do
Caption: is we ignore the input we don't care
Caption: what feature toggle it is we'll just
Caption: always return false
Caption: we can implement the feature toggle down
Caption: here in the closure
Caption: so is this a feature toggle
Caption: i think it is it looks like it looks
Caption: like one to me right it implements the
Caption: feature toggle interface
Caption: it returns
Caption: the correct value something that i'm
Caption: kind of expecting it's a boolean
Caption: but i'm looking at this and i'm going
Caption: there's a lot of superfluous code here i
Caption: don't really need half of this right
Caption: i'm always getting the same value from
Caption: this feature toggle it's always false so
Caption: why don't i just do a bit of refactoring
Caption: right
Caption: what if i just remove
Caption: some of that feature toggle stuff and i
Caption: just drop that false in there so it's
Caption: always because it's always going to be
Caption: false
Caption: is this a feature toggle well it doesn't
Caption: say it's a feature toggle anymore
Caption: there's no interface i'm not
Caption: implementing a feature toggle interface
Caption: but i think this still is a feature
Caption: toggle
Caption: let's go a step further
Caption: if my compiler's having a look at this
Caption: so i'm using typescript although this
Caption: code kind of looks like it's just
Caption: javascript by now
Caption: if i'm using typescript typestrip's
Caption: going to have a look at that and start
Caption: to make efficiencies here and there and
Caption: it doesn't really matter if it's
Caption: typescript or other compilers that
Caption: mostly do this
Caption: it'll look at that if false statement
Caption: and go what's the point in that there's
Caption: it's i don't like i'm never going to
Caption: execute that code on line five it's i
Caption: might as well get rid of it so let's say
Caption: the compiler has a go in it um just
Caption: removes that
Caption: is that a feature toggle
Caption: not looking much like a feature toggle
Caption: anymore but i still believe that that is
Caption: that might look a bit strange but i did
Caption: title my talk everything's a feature
Caption: toggle so i had to work something like
Caption: that in there
Caption: um yeah it doesn't look like a feature
Caption: talk was just a bit of code but yeah
Caption: that is
Caption: i'm going to give this feature toggle a
Caption: name i don't think there's commonly used
Caption: names for a lot of this stuff so
Caption: these names are just made up by me but
Caption: i'm going to call this a static toggle
Caption: and a static toggle is categorized by
Caption: being persisted in code so i don't have
Caption: to ask
Caption: some database or some file for the value
Caption: of this one it's just in the code
Caption: i get static and very consistent
Caption: evaluation it's basically just always
Caption: false it's very very predictable and
Caption: that's nice
Caption: and this is a tool you can do
Caption: you can use to do a thing called
Caption: branching by abstraction
Caption: so
Caption: let's talk about what that means
Caption: let's say we have um some old code that
Caption: we want to replace we've got a new
Caption: version maybe a new version of an
Caption: algorithm that we want um to put in
Caption: there that's more efficient
Caption: but what we want to do is that algorithm
Caption: is going to take a little bit of back
Caption: and forth maybe it's going to be
Caption: multiple commits to our repository it's
Caption: going to take a little while to write
Caption: i want to i want guarantees that i can
Caption: start writing that code make commits
Caption: maybe someone else can kind of um
Caption: collaborate with me but i want
Caption: guarantees that that code that i've got
Caption: in that term in my repository is not
Caption: going to run right
Caption: so what i could do
Caption: is
Caption: do a commit um i don't have to do a
Caption: commit and push all of this up but like
Caption: the first change i might look at making
Caption: is putting a feature toggle in front of
Caption: it and this can be an always off feature
Caption: toggle so i'm always going to go down to
Caption: that
Caption: old code path so it doesn't really
Caption: matter what on what's on that new code
Caption: path there at the top at the moment
Caption: there's nothing i haven't put anything
Caption: in yet
Caption: then what i might do is start working on
Caption: that new algorithm and if i'm just
Caption: playing around locally i can switch that
Caption: to an always-on toggle as long as i
Caption: don't commit that anywhere
Caption: i can start working with that new
Caption: algorithm test the performance do stuff
Caption: like that i can commit that
Caption: and let one of my colleagues have a play
Caption: around with it and see if they can make
Caption: it more efficient
Caption: i get a guarantee that i know that
Caption: code's not going to run
Caption: in production it's not going to make it
Caption: into
Caption: into the hands of users which is quite
Caption: nice
Caption: once i'm ready
Caption: i can flip that feature toggle from
Caption: being always off to always on or i might
Caption: have some other feature toggling
Caption: strategy there
Caption: i'll talk about more of those in a
Caption: minute but
Caption: once i'm ready basically i'm going to
Caption: start executing code on that new code
Caption: path
Caption: and then when i'm happy with the final
Caption: solution here
Caption: it looks like it's running perfectly
Caption: fine the last step i can do is just to
Caption: remove both the feature toggle and the
Caption: old version of code it's quite a safe
Caption: approach to incrementally adding new
Caption: features and that's what branch by
Caption: abstraction is
Caption: so this is a quote from martin feller's
Caption: article about feature toggles um
Caption: specifically in the context of what i've
Caption: just talked about
Caption: feature toggles are an interesting way
Caption: to allow incomplete and untested code
Caption: paths to be shipped to production as
Caption: latent code i sometimes call it floating
Caption: code
Caption: but the idea of that is that we get
Caption: guarantees that it will never be turned
Caption: on it'll ever be executed which is quite
Caption: nice
Caption: let's uh go back to our static toggle
Caption: for a minute
Caption: um let's just work through an
Caption: implementation just so we get an idea of
Caption: what that might actually look like
Caption: so
Caption: what we have here is uh i'm looking at
Caption: implementing a new version of my payment
Caption: gateway um maybe we've moved from xml
Caption: and soap to something a bit nicer like
Caption: json
Caption: the idea here is that
Caption: the input and output basically the
Caption: interface to this plane and gateway's
Caption: the same that's how we can use branch by
Caption: abstraction here so i've got both
Caption: implementations here and what i can do
Caption: is i can use the feature toggle i'll put
Caption: a feature toggle in front of it and we
Caption: can see that that feature toggle is by
Caption: default it's always off but my
Caption: implementation here um if if my feature
Caption: tag was actually turned on at this given
Caption: time i'd use that new gateway
Caption: um so yeah i can see where i've always
Caption: i've defaulted always off here
Caption: here's some unit tests because we always
Caption: have to test our code
Caption: and what we can see here is
Caption: we've got this one test suite we're
Caption: going to
Caption: test
Caption: this old version of our gateway and a
Caption: new version of a gateway with the same
Caption: test suite because we know that they
Caption: should behave the same mostly
Caption: if we run our tests
Caption: with the old gateway we can run it with
Caption: that always off feature toggle there
Caption: and if we want to test our new gateway
Caption: we can test it with that always-on
Caption: feature toggle there we'll get the same
Caption: test suite over both
Caption: we can plot feature toggles
Caption: on a on a graph i guess
Caption: plotting longevity versus evaluation
Caption: and our static toggles land in this sort
Caption: of bottom corner down here they're
Caption: grouped under a section of toggles
Caption: called i call release toggles
Caption: and the idea is you might use something
Caption: like this for a couple of days while
Caption: you're collaborating on some new code
Caption: that you're writing not going to be
Caption: using these all the time by the way as
Caption: well
Caption: and in terms of how how they're
Caption: evaluated you get
Caption: they kind of don't they land completely
Caption: in that static kind of area down there
Caption: let's uh continue on with some more
Caption: different types of fiji toggles
Caption: so this is an environment toggle um a
Caption: lot of people might be quite familiar
Caption: with something like this if you do a lot
Caption: of node.js development but there'll be
Caption: equivalence in other languages as well
Caption: these are also persisted in code
Caption: and the idea here is you might evaluate
Caption: this at either build time or startup
Caption: so
Caption: if you're doing a web application using
Caption: webpack you're actually evaluating stuff
Caption: like this at build time and you're
Caption: building different versions of your
Caption: application
Caption: whereas other frameworks you might be
Caption: doing that at startup you'll decide okay
Caption: i'm starting out what environment am i
Caption: in i'm going to set all my features
Caption: there
Caption: and these are great sorry i'll go back
Caption: for a sec these are great for
Caption: integration and uat testing you might
Caption: have multiple environments you want
Caption: features on in this environment but not
Caption: that environment obviously
Caption: uh how are they used
Caption: uh what we have here is
Caption: we've got a feature that we're wanting
Caption: to use
Caption: we've got this environment toggle here
Caption: essentially we're checking if we're in
Caption: the development environment
Caption: in our development environment we want
Caption: to play around with toggles have
Caption: different stuff running so we can see
Caption: we check for that
Caption: and then yeah
Caption: if we're looking at our dev toggles here
Caption: we can check if we're matching certain
Caption: toggles what we want to have on what we
Caption: want to have off at the time
Caption: but we get a guarantee here that
Caption: if we're not in the development
Caption: environment we turn everything off
Caption: everything's every every new features
Caption: there
Caption: is off that's really nice because um it
Caption: gives you guarantee that you're not
Caption: gonna accidentally run any of the
Caption: software in the wrong environment um not
Caption: when it's not ready
Caption: environment toggles will are the sort of
Caption: thing that are built into your software
Caption: development life cycle
Caption: so they'll last a little bit longer
Caption: they'll go beyond just collaborating and
Caption: experimenting with code they're built
Caption: into the testing process so like i said
Caption: you'll use them in your uat or
Caption: integration environments
Caption: and they trend over towards the the
Caption: right a little bit in terms of um when
Caption: they're evaluated so either build time
Caption: or start up
Caption: moving on this is actually the type of
Caption: feature talk that i was most familiar
Caption: with um when i started
Caption: uh
Caption: using them i guess
Caption: this is an application toggle
Caption: and these are the most flexible so the
Caption: idea is that the persistence will vary
Caption: when i was talking about
Caption: where can your feature toggle be
Caption: persisted could it be in a database or
Caption: in code or in a nosql database or
Caption: something like that that's usually
Caption: talking about these types of feature
Caption: doubles here so this example
Caption: runs against the sql database i'm
Caption: running a sql query to decide whether
Caption: this feature toggles on or off
Caption: and i can do that i can evaluate that
Caption: either at startup application starts up
Caption: i'll decide what's what's enabled what's
Caption: not
Caption: or
Caption: i can do that per request as well i can
Caption: turn things on and off while people are
Caption: using this application
Caption: talking about them being versatile and
Caption: extendable
Caption: what we could do is we could tweak the
Caption: interface a little bit if we wanted so
Caption: we can create a user toggle which
Caption: accepts two parameters instead of one
Caption: we've got the feature name but also a
Caption: user id
Caption: and then what we can do is enable
Caption: features for certain users so a canary
Caption: toggle is a toggle based on
Caption: identifiers
Caption: identifiers of your user but not
Caption: necessarily user maybe other things as
Caption: well
Caption: probably want to evaluate these ones per
Caption: request if you've got a lot of users you
Caption: can't really evaluate this once at
Caption: startup so this is something you do per
Caption: request
Caption: and this is useful for canary releases
Caption: but hence the name
Caption: right another type of toggle you might
Caption: use um in this kind of familiar to this
Caption: one as well is a calculated toggle
Caption: so the idea here is um these are these
Caption: go back to being persisted in code
Caption: um we're not going to ask a database for
Caption: something like that but what we'll do is
Caption: we'll do a calculation of those per user
Caption: attributes so something like the user id
Caption: um and we'll use that in order to split
Caption: our traffic um in a certain way what we
Caption: can do is
Caption: this example here we've got a hash
Caption: um
Caption: you don't want to see how that sausage
Caption: is made it's it's uh there's quite a
Caption: complex little algorithm there but the
Caption: idea is you input a string and you get a
Caption: number that's somewhere between one and
Caption: zero and what we can do is our
Caption: calculator toggle just checks if that
Caption: number is greater than 0.05 that's
Caption: actually going to split our cohort
Caption: essentially in half
Caption: again you'd evaluate this per request
Caption: and this is something you'd use in a b
Caption: testing
Caption: so we can see these three types of
Caption: feature toggles they they uh they land
Caption: in this kind of section called
Caption: experiment toggles
Caption: uh what we can see is
Caption: um they trend more towards the right
Caption: where they're evaluated typically per
Caption: request although sometimes not
Caption: and these are something you'll leave in
Caption: your system a little bit longer still
Caption: something you want to have running in
Caption: production you can play around with turn
Caption: things off and on
Caption: there's another type of feature toggle
Caption: this is a circuit breaker so like a
Caption: canary toggle or a calculated toggle is
Caption: a calculation of user attributes a
Caption: circuit breaker is slightly different
Caption: it's a
Caption: it's based on a calculation of your
Caption: current system health
Caption: um so what you want to do is evaluate
Caption: that probably per request as well you
Caption: wouldn't want to evaluate that at
Caption: startup because your system help at
Caption: startup's not the same as it's going to
Caption: be later on
Caption: and then in this example what we're
Caption: doing here is um
Caption: uh we're checking for queue depth so
Caption: essentially if if our queue is getting
Caption: too long if we've got too many things to
Caption: process what we can do is return files
Caption: and we can back off we can
Caption: essentially stop adding new things to
Caption: that queue
Caption: we can disable features if our system
Caption: health
Caption: isn't looking too good
Caption: these are really useful for operational
Caption: purposes
Caption: similarly
Caption: there's the idea of a kill switch as
Caption: well so this code example
Caption: is for an express middleware and we can
Caption: actually see a different feature toggles
Caption: embedded in there but the idea here is
Caption: we can just disable an entire endpoint
Caption: that we don't we don't want to um
Caption: our customers to have access to maybe
Caption: something's broken it's not working or
Caption: maybe that endpoint is being abused
Caption: and this is essentially just a manually
Caption: managed circuit breaker so we'll notice
Caption: a problem um the difference here is it's
Caption: not automated whether that feature
Caption: toggles on or off we're doing that
Caption: manually yourself
Caption: these feature toggles
Caption: um because they're operational toggles
Caption: they're going to last a lot longer in
Caption: our system we don't really know when
Caption: exactly we're going to need to use these
Caption: or not they're probably going to live in
Caption: your system a little bit longer
Caption: um so longevity is somewhere up in in
Caption: months maybe even indefinitely
Caption: and we can also see
Caption: as well the the there's an overlap there
Caption: with that application toggle as well so
Caption: you can use those um you might have seen
Caption: inside the kill switch there was that
Caption: application toggle as well
Caption: um so you can see some overlap there
Caption: the last category of feature toggles i
Caption: want to talk about is something called
Caption: customization
Caption: um so you might have heard customization
Caption: versus personalization before
Caption: talk about that in a sec but
Caption: this example here i haven't got any code
Caption: to show you but this example here is
Caption: github so they've got a little feature
Caption: preview model that you can access
Caption: and if you're if you want you can enable
Caption: certain features that they're currently
Caption: running through they don't want everyone
Caption: to have access to it but if you're
Caption: interested in using that feature you can
Caption: enable that yourself
Caption: um you have control over it that's the
Caption: important part that differentiates
Caption: customization versus personalization
Caption: so these customizations are the sort of
Caption: thing you might want to run for a longer
Caption: period of time as well
Caption: they fall under a category of toggles
Caption: called permission toggles we can see
Caption: that the canary lives in here as well
Caption: this is the differentiation between
Caption: customization and personalization so
Caption: personalization are those canary toggles
Caption: and personalizations are the the
Caption: difference there is whether we as the
Caption: developers or the people making the
Caption: product
Caption: deciding whether those feature toggles
Caption: are shown to those customers all those
Caption: features are versus customization those
Caption: customers are opting in themselves
Caption: so i've shown you a bunch of different
Caption: types of feature toggles and what they
Caption: look like let's quickly talk about some
Caption: techniques and strategy
Caption: so if you remember branching by
Caption: abstraction in our trunk based
Caption: development stuff
Caption: before when we had feature branches what
Caption: we did is we we put all of our branching
Caption: into our source control so we'd have
Caption: lots of branches running different
Caption: versions of the software there and that
Caption: was quite hard to manage many many
Caption: branches lots of merge conflicts when
Caption: we're trying to merge things over the
Caption: top of each other
Caption: difficult right branching is bad
Caption: but we did have versions of our code
Caption: that didn't have as many branches in
Caption: them so we'd have this linear code
Caption: execution paths
Caption: when we moved to trunk based development
Caption: we didn't solve that problem all we did
Caption: was move it so we moved our branching
Caption: our stuff that's hard that we don't
Caption: really like we move that into our code
Caption: that's not necessarily bad like code's
Caption: easier to work with it's it's nicer and
Caption: we get more flexibility and control
Caption: whereas source control's a bit rigid and
Caption: has limitations right
Caption: but we just moved the problem that's
Caption: important to note
Caption: so
Caption: there's three things that are
Caption: potentially true of any long-lived
Caption: feature branch this is feature branches
Caption: um in our old way of working
Caption: any feature branch that's been around
Caption: for a long time has either already been
Caption: merged
Caption: or it can't be merged there's too many
Caption: conflicts it's not possible anymore
Caption: or it's code that's no longer relevant
Caption: it's been superseded by something else
Caption: and the same
Caption: three or similar three
Caption: characteristics are true of any feature
Caption: toggle you've had in your system for a
Caption: very long period of time
Caption: so those feature toggles are permanently
Caption: on
Caption: or they're permanently off so you can
Caption: remove them
Caption: otherwise if they're somewhere in the
Caption: middle like they're a canary that's been
Caption: running for a very long period of time
Caption: you're actually probably at the stage
Caption: with that isn't a feature toggle anymore
Caption: it's actually part of your business
Caption: logic
Caption: so we want to be removing toggles where
Caption: we can our idea here is that
Caption: basically in all three of these cases
Caption: here we can we can remove that feature
Caption: toggle if it's been around for a very
Caption: long period of time so
Caption: let's make sure we remove our feature
Caption: toggles
Caption: essentially one thing to remember here
Caption: one thing to take away is that every
Caption: feature toggle should have an expiry so
Caption: here's an interesting piece of code this
Caption: is a test
Caption: um
Caption: what we have here is the toggle like
Caption: it's a test that fails um if your
Caption: feature toggle is still in the system
Caption: after one month
Caption: i wouldn't recommend doing this because
Caption: what happens with something like this is
Caption: yeah your developer who's working on the
Caption: code at the time sees this random test
Caption: failing um and what they'll do is
Caption: they'll just remove that test so that
Caption: isn't going to work very well or they'll
Caption: change the date to 2022. developers are
Caption: lazy
Caption: so
Caption: the best way to approach this instead is
Caption: to remove feature toggles proactively
Caption: make an effort to do it um make sure you
Caption: go and check and see if anything's still
Caption: still in use and don't do that yourself
Caption: but do it proactively
Caption: the other lesson
Caption: is naming toggles so i've got a feature
Caption: toggle here it's called internal staff
Caption: and we can see it uses one version of a
Caption: payment gateway or another
Caption: internal staff or not
Caption: problem here is this feature toggle's
Caption: naming is a bit vague and
Caption: if i dig a little bit what i find is
Caption: that it's being used in other places so
Caption: this isn't good
Caption: the problem here is i've got a feature
Caption: toggle
Caption: that
Caption: when i turn it on i actually don't
Caption: really know all the things that it could
Caption: be potentially either enabling or
Caption: disabling it's not very specific
Caption: looks like here i get a new version of a
Caption: payment gateway
Caption: but also i send different emails and i
Caption: use different algorithms so do i want to
Caption: turn this on or not
Caption: so it's important to be specific
Caption: we're talking about names let's try and
Caption: come up with a better name right
Caption: what if we took the jira ticket and just
Caption: stuck that in there well now you've got
Caption: this problem where if i'm looking at a
Caption: feature toggle and wanting to work out
Caption: what it does i now have to jump into
Caption: jira and i don't really like euro it's
Caption: slow and hard i'm just i'm
Caption: putting in indirection for the sake of
Caption: it so that's not great so avoid
Caption: indirection as well
Caption: the other thing is naming wise don't be
Caption: don't be cutesy because that's the same
Caption: thing that's just in direction as well
Caption: so
Caption: if i'm looking at that feature toggle
Caption: this feature toggle called george i
Caption: don't know what that does if i've just
Caption: got that i haven't got this i haven't
Caption: got the code i'm just looking at george
Caption: it doesn't tell me what it does so
Caption: probably a best the best version
Caption: of a name for this particular feature
Caption: toggle is use old payment gateway or
Caption: something like that so that if it's on i
Caption: know i'm going to that old payment
Caption: gateway
Caption: lastly i think it's important to also
Caption: make sure you have an audit log of some
Caption: kind
Caption: when you're using feature toggles
Caption: just because
Caption: you're changing the way your application
Caption: works right so
Caption: if there's something that goes wrong as
Caption: a result of that we really need to know
Caption: uh
Caption: i guess when when that change happens so
Caption: that we can kind of track that down and
Caption: make sure that
Caption: we're able to fix that so it's a
Caption: debugging
Caption: it's a debugging problem
Caption: so if we go and look at all the
Caption: different types of feature toggles that
Caption: we have
Caption: using an audit log kind of differs
Caption: depending on what you're doing
Caption: when you have these
Caption: static and environment toggles it's
Caption: actually really easy you've already got
Caption: an audit log because those those feature
Caption: toggles live in code so
Caption: um anything that lives in code is
Caption: already audited by source control that's
Caption: really nice we don't have to do anything
Caption: if you've got some of these
Caption: database driven ones or these
Caption: application feature toggles
Caption: what you might want to use is a change
Caption: log and you want that change log to live
Caption: probably close to where the actual value
Caption: of the feature toggles persisted
Caption: so if you're putting your feature
Caption: talkers in a database have a secondary
Caption: table that tells us when those feature
Caption: toggles were changed
Caption: and lastly if you've got one of the
Caption: calculated styles of feature toggles so
Caption: the circuit breaker or a calculated a b
Caption: test feature toggle um you need some
Caption: sort of decision log just log when a
Caption: decision was made
Caption: about enabling a feature or disabling a
Caption: feature that can that doesn't actually
Caption: have to be too complicated just log
Caption: message send it to your log aggregator
Caption: and then you can just track it later
Caption: cool so these are the lessons the
Caption: techniques
Caption: remove feature toggles proactively use
Caption: deliberate and descriptive naming and
Caption: make sure to use an audit log that's
Caption: really important
Caption: cool
Caption: so i think it's important to look back
Caption: over the history of software development
Caption: and draw from some of the lessons that
Caption: we've learned
Caption: over this journey so we might assume
Caption: that techniques like feature toggling
Caption: they kind of just appeared one day but
Caption: the reality is we went through a journey
Caption: of
Caption: lots of failures and learning from those
Caption: failures
Caption: we talked about the many forms of
Caption: uh feature toggle that you can have
Caption: um and how they map in terms of
Caption: um
Caption: sorry how they map in terms of uh
Caption: plotting them in terms of evaluation
Caption: versus longevity so evaluation being how
Caption: often are we are we looking for that
Caption: value and how often does that value
Caption: change
Caption: versus
Caption: how long we just we
Caption: deciding that feature toggle is going to
Caption: live for in our system
Caption: and like any technique that we have in
Caption: software development and software
Caption: architecture there's always going to be
Caption: trade-offs
Caption: so
Caption: the best example here is we wanted to
Caption: avoid branching and source control
Caption: because it was rigid and it was
Caption: difficult and merge conflicts are hard
Caption: right
Caption: but all we ended up doing was taking
Caption: that branching strategy and moving that
Caption: somewhere else it moved into our code so
Caption: now we have to have appropriate
Caption: mechanisms to deal with that as well
Caption: be aware of some of the techniques that
Caption: we have at our disposal and the many
Caption: ways that we can use them
Caption: as well as how to use them properly
Caption: use feature toggles as a tool to plan
Caption: for the unexpected
Caption: because the unexpected is something
Caption: that's always going to happen take this
Caption: picture and basically the whole story of
Caption: this movie
Caption: uh planning for the unexpected can make
Caption: a huge difference to the difference to
Caption: the success of your product
Caption: but also the experience for your
Caption: customers
Caption: i'm going to thank the sponsors again um
Caption: as i can
Caption: but also i want to point out that i work
Caption: for one of the companies on this slide
Caption: that's these guys here
Caption: if
Caption: uh feature toggles and the idea of using
Caption: them is interesting to you we use them a
Caption: lot we play around with the various
Caption: different versions and as well um we're
Caption: also hiring i'm up here doing the the
Caption: hiring spiel because
Caption: we're looking for people so if if you're
Caption: interested come talk to me or um we have
Caption: a booth down in in the back corner
Caption: with jacob and travis down there i'll
Caption: give you a free pair of socks if you
Caption: haven't got them already they look
Caption: really cool
Caption: that's been me thank you
Caption: you